[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in ross tucker our good
buddy the ross tucker football podcast
he works for cbs in westwood one the
former offensive lineman uh
boy could you imagine having the task of
trying to stop aaron donald there in the
final five seven ten minutes of that
game there ross
oh yeah i can imagine
there's there's a guy that went in the
hall of fame
over the weekend brian young
who was not aaron donald but was a
similar type of player and i've actually
talked to guys about the best way to try
to block aaron donald some guys dan will
try to just jump him and grab him right
there but he's so good with his hands
that you can look real bad so people
i've talked to said oh the best move is
to just set back a little bit give a
little bit ground well he was bull
rushing the crap out of those guys last
night i'm not sure there is
a really good answer when they were
double teaming him and sliding to him
that helped it is funny though because i
don't know if you've ever done this with
him on your show i know you have the
guys read their draft profiles but it's
so funny because he didn't go top 10
because people were worried about how
short he was it's just it just seems so
funny now by the way like who cares how
tall you are for a defensive tackle
who uh who would you have given the mvp
to
co-mvps cooper cup and aaron donald now
that's okay you can't do that you got to
give it to somebody one person oh okay
um well there has been a year though
where there was co-mvps
um
if you have to give it to somebody i
don't have a problem with cooper cup it
would not have been stafford i don't
think no i think it would have been cup
or donald uh you know the thing that
people are forgetting
is after stafford through the
interception on the rams first offensive
play
aaron donald had two sacks you know the
bengals had just gotten the bomb the t
higgins
they're up 17-13 then they get the
interception by a woozier
donald chases joe burrow out of bounds
and then third down higgins is open
donald bull rushes identity and gets a
sack those that was huge if the bengals
score a touchdown there
i think the game is very very different
and then he closed it out at the end as
well i think you can make a strong
argument for aaron donald but i'm fine
with cooper cup too he took over that
last drive
even when it seemed like he was the only
legit weapon the rams could really go to
how could the bengals have won this
well several different ways first of all
it's kind of crazy to me dan that they
ran the ball so much better than the
rams did and lost
real you know if you would have told me
that bengals would run it that much
better than the rams and lose the game i
would have been surprised
i have to be honest with you i was a
little disappointed in joe burrow in the
second half of the game and i know the
way it is right you have a young
quarterback he's very good
there's going to be 5 000 bengals fans
are going to jump all over me because
they don't like if you say anything bad
at all
dan he just takes sacks that you cannot
take
he puts his team in a situation where
they have very little chance to get a
first down
on that series of downs he missed a
critical throw to jamar chase
when chase was wide open on a third down
that would have been a first down would
have kept the drive alive
so i i really thought
that
burrow was fine
bro had a good game but for the bengals
to win that game
they needed him to be better in the
second half they need him to be clutch
and he kind of cowered a little bit to
the pressure you know he took some sacks
where he saw the guy coming
throw the ball away try to give one of
your receivers a chance you just can't
keep taking sacks like he did
how do you explain the rams defense
being so dominating in the second half
or certainly in that fourth fourth
quarter
well i think one thing they did was they
did a better job
of having five guys up
so that the offensive line couldn't
automatically slide to aaron donald i'm
a little surprised that the rams didn't
do that in the first half you know it's
simple math right you got 4d linemen
rushing five offensive linemen you can
send the center to help out on whoever's
blocking aaron down the whole time when
they would walk the linebackers up like
reader or ernest jones or even guys off
the edge well then those five big guys
they got to block the five guys they
think are coming they were able to get a
lot more one-on-ones for guys than they
had in the first half and they clearly
took advantage
what did you make of the uh officiating
last night
okay
okay um i i was disappointed
really disappointed
in the holding penalty against logan
wilson
on third down about a minute and a half
left i thought it was perfect coverage
on cooper cup i'm of the belief dan when
in doubt don't throw the flag they had
let the guys play all game all game they
let them play
and then it wasn't even ticky tack to me
there was no foul there at all i thought
it was an excellent play by logan wilson
i thought it was the worst call of the
game however
the first play of the second half
t higgins clearly tugged jalen ramsey's
face mask which is how he got open and
scored so if you want to say that those
two calls kind of offset each other i
can live with that but i would always
rather have the no call than throwing
the flag for a foul that's not there in
general though i don't think it's the
reason why the rams won the game i don't
think it should be the main topic of
conversation today and as long as that's
the case i'll say they did an okay job
more likely to get back to the super
bowl next year
rams bengals
i think they both have a really tough
task of doing that but i'll go with the
rams you know that the two favorites to
win the super bowl next year dan are the
chiefs and the bills
you know in the afc
that's going to be rough for the bengals
i mean rough they got a good young team
but
i heard you talking about it before you
brought me on
you know it is not as easy to get back
as these teams think it is it is very
very hard
i think kansas city and buffalo they're
both going to think that they're going
to do be due to get back i think it's
going to be tough for the bengals to get
back to the super bowl next year i'm not
they might be able to get back there
again
next year would be tough the nfc is just
much more open
and the rams seem much more open to
doing whatever it takes
to try to get this going while they have
this window so maybe aaron dowell needs
some more money that's fine i think
they'll try to find a way to bring vonn
back
we'll see with odell after that injury
now but the rams are very much a win now
this is our window
and i think it's not just
because of the players on their team i
think it's the dynamic of them being in
los angeles
trying to capture the hearts and minds
of the fans out there while they have
this new stadium there's multiple
reasons why i think the rams are in win
now mode i think they'll be very good
again next year what do you do if you're
the bengals in the offseason
well it's going to be heavy offensive
line i think we know that um i think
they're good at skill they're in a good
spot dan
where they they can't even pay burrow
yet they can't even pay jamar chase yet
a lot of times these guys you'd be like
oh man are the bengals gonna sign this
guy or is he gonna go somewhere else
they got no place else to go so they're
in a really good spot i think they'll
probably add one veteran free agent on
the offensive line they'll probably
draft an offensive lineman as well
probably still go in the secondary i'm
not sure they they love eli apple being
but this is a pretty good team they're
not far away they're gonna be in the mix
i i just don't think they'll end up
being the chiefs and the bills again but
they're gonna get the offensive line
better they're gonna be in the mix let
me go back to you talking about aaron
donald maybe getting a new contract or
wanting more money do you think that's
the ploy of him saying to rodney
harrison that you know i may walk away
if i win a super bowl
i don't think that's why he's saying it
i think it's something he's legitimately
considered and i got to tell you
this does not bother me right you know
he's a smart guy
he's done everything he could really do
as a player most people think he's one
of the best defensive players ever
he's already made a ton of money
you know dan with cte
and with everyone knowing the long-term
ramifications
of playing especially defensive tackle
the amount of double teams he takes the
amount of shots he takes if he says you
know what i had an awesome eight years
i'm gonna go live the rest of my life be
able to be with my family healthy my
shoulders and knees are okay
my brain i think like i don't need to do
this anymore
i think that would be wonderful i'd be
happy for him
but
it seems like when these guys are away
from it for a couple months
and then they start to think okay what
would i do next
and it's not going to be the 14 and a
half million the rams are supposed to
pay them and like i said
if that's what it takes
the rams i think will sweeten the pile a
little bit be like aaron how about how's
20 million sound i think that's hard to
turn down you know you realize
i want to live 60 more years
over 20 million dollars i think he'll
end up playing i'd be surprised if he
retires but i wouldn't be surprised if
he gets a little contract sweetener to
do so
great to talk to you buddy thanks and uh
we hope to continue to talk to you in
the off season
my pleasure dan thank you so much for
having me on so much this year it's been
fun that's ross tucker host of the ross
tucker football podcast and also even
money podcast you can find him on social
media at ross tucker nfl